make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so I changed my setup I'm actually down
here in the basement right now but in
this video I wanted to talk about like
venom in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
because this is a really really cool
prospect was really interesting idea
because there's a lot that they can do
with it alright here's here's one of the
things Sony as far as I'm aware has the
whole venom thing but I don't know the
details of the contract that was worked
out between themselves and Disney and in
reality after you'd have a hard time
finding the the like the wording of it I
mean I'm sure that contract is under
lock and key
right I mean have things hidden away
it's like it's like the the formula to
Coca Cola right I mean remember however
is okay if you please talk about how
secretive that was I'm a little bit's if
it's still a secret but um in any event
venom in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
presents a really interesting scenario
because what you're talking about here
is the notion of taking what's arguably
the most popular spider-man villain and
then filling him in to the MCU but the
reality of this is it may it may create
like some some conflict right because
when you think about this like like
Sony's just started their whole venom
thing and and as far as I'm aware it's
supposed to be a trilogy and the venom
line the venom line of films is supposed
to kind of set in stone so knees like
villain verse right like everybody's
gonna be focusing on villains instead of
focusing on heroes because they don't
have spider-man and that's how to
spider-man they don't have anybody else
so literally all they can do is focus on
villains which is why I'm kind of under
the impression that like Marvel and
Disney owned the rights to spider-man
like entirely like that's that's it but
in any event if you take if you take
venom and you film into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's a zillion
possibilities they can do right because
what what's so dinner for Sony to really
do venom effectively which is to say to
do them in film form and actually
explore the venom universe they're gonna
need more than what they have right now
um right now like like in in Marvel
Comics the way it used to be this is the
way the Venom's to me the concept used
to be that the venom Samiha was
basically a costume I'm not really a
costume he was just kind of an organism
that existed on a planet during the
event of the original Secret Wars in
1984 and then Peter Parker in the
process of trying to find a new costume
stumbled upon the symbiote and in the
the Soumya and it basically bonded
itself to him and when that happened
he basically ended up you know going
back to earth once Secret Wars was done
brought The Scindia back with him and
then in turn it wasn't until like Reed
Richards of the Fantastic Four told him
this thing's actually alive and that's
why you were having these quote-unquote
nightmares where you're going out in the
venom simian and doing things because he
actually was you know he just didn't
realize he was effectively sleepwalking
and being controlled by the Symbian and
and then of course Peter Parker cast it
off of him it bonded itself to Eddie
Brock and then the grass is history
right like I mean you know Eddie Brock
as venom went forward is like
spider-man's most popular villain I say
the mana state most probably not the
most significant but some of the most
popular I think Green Goblin Norman
Osborn is the most significant but in
terms of popularity Venom's right up
here there's a reason why you've never
seen a Green Goblin movie right like you
saw him as a villain but you've never
seen a standalone Green Goblin movie and
all honesty I don't think you ever will
cuz I mean what's the Green Goblin if
he's not fighting spider-man and so I
mean I guess people say the same thing
about venom but then you got agent venom
and things like that but that's that's
kind of where I go into this is because
what you're doing is you're talking you
know in in the mono Cinematic Universe
you're talking about how things changed
in Marvel Comics in and of themselves
recently if the like Bionic hates the
whole thing was we worked and what you
ended up having was like way back when
you had this being called no hay and ulo
and no it was basically this guy from
like a different dimension for like this
dark you know this void dimension
whatever was and showed up in the main
Marvel Universe and then in turn was
like defeat of other Celestials after
crafting this weapon called the
all-black necro sword and then in turn
like the Celestials kind of cast him out
or defeated him but that basically led
to him like creating the symbionts and
then in doing so like they basically
spread throughout the cosmos now after
his defeat and his supposed death they
had no leader and so when they spread
throughout the cosmos that went into
Brian Michael Bendis is run planning to
the symbiotes during guardians of the
galaxy where basically the semi it's
kind of reworked themselves became their
own civilization their own stories
legends myths so on and so forth and
basically became these kind of space
Knights in the sense that like the
symbionts would normally bond themselves
to a person and they would go forward
and become a superhero basically
somebody protecting their section of the
universe rights like imagine imagine it
being something akin to like the Green
Lantern's - hard like constructs and
then of course that basically led to
spider-man finding the finally the
Samiha tier in Secret Wars and then
because of the fact that he casts it off
it made the symbiote like this enemy I
got mad at him and
banda themselves to Eddie Brock and then
it became a villain and so like you're
talking about like a total reworking of
the the simian mythos but the reason why
all that works is because you're talking
about building up on a huge amount on a
huge legacy venom has had crosses
crossovers and dealings with the
veritable who's who of Marvel Comics
Captain America the Avengers the x-men I
think like it at some point along the
line I mean he's like you literally saw
spider-man and venom team up against
against carnage during the events of
maximum carnage I mean you've seen like
a lot of heat and even characters have
shifted right like most people know
Eddie Brock as being venom but there are
a lot of fans out there who will look
and say Flash Thompson as agent venom is
the best version of the character right
like Flash Thompson that lost his legs
during during during the war and then in
turn like when he came back he basically
had the semi a bonded to him and it went
forward and basically became like a good
guy right like that's really what he was
he was a person with a venom stood me up
being a good guy and like he would talk
to it and different things along those
lines and of course again like later on
kind of building on that the symbiote
sort of became a good guy in and of
itself so there was a lot of development
on the symbian itself but in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in order to apply the
Simien properly I mean it would take you
you would you would really have to you
couldn't just bring him in for one movie
well you couldn't just bring in venom
and then have him there for a single
film and then that's it you would need
him for like multiple films for like you
know for really to be like a mainstay of
the character I mean I don't know if I
would if I would make like a standalone
venom film in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because you already have one
especially if it's one of these things
where like Sony and Marvel is sharing
him and so like between venom 2 & 3 he
crosses over to the MCU or something
like that but with regards to the
multiverse and with regards to to the
fact that you know spider-man's in
earth-616 now according to the clip that
we saw this means a couple things the
first thing is that if if spider-man is
part of earth-616
that were really really like if I'm
sorry if the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is now earth-616 then what it means is
that everything in the comics is in
continuity every everything has ever
happened in Marvel Comics
depending on when this when when it
takes place right I mean if the Marvel
Cinematic Universe takes is like five
years ahead of Marvel Comics no
technically all this stuff has not
happened yet right like but you would
have but but because the fact that is
referred to as earth-616 that basically
means that like everything in the
comments does happen oh this creates a
whole
huge mess in terms of continuity and in
all kinds of stuff so that's why a lot
of people are drawing the conclusion
that Mysterio's long available and just
like he picked a random number or it was
like making it all up or whatever the
case is but like none of its true
right he's just he threw a number out
there randomly and it's a you know kind
of really on the nose Easter Egg for for
Marvel Comics whatever the case is but
grabbing venom throwing him in I think
it works and it's an awesome idea but
the the issue with this is that you run
into some continuity issues with regards
to what Sony's doing it all kind of has
to sync and match up and you're
basically talking about the idea of
grabbing him and bringing him in from a
different universe and the problem with
that is that it opens up a opens up with
a kind of Pandora's box of easiness
right like if we just open up a all
straight reality and then we could have
the Avengers and grab the x-men and we
throw them in and we open up an
alternate reality or the Fantastic Four
and bring them in
it takes away from from the the journey
and the experience of being part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe right because
what made it so cool was kind of seeing
these small little Easter eggs and after
the question like how are they gonna get
the man were they gonna come from the
theorycrafting
right like that was the fun part of
there's a reason why YouTube videos get
like millions of views by saying like
what you know what if they brought them
in this way or swimming along those
lines it's something that I love to do
and it's something that you guys love to
do by removing that element it kind of
takes away from things and so in reality
I love the idea of it I'm in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but in truth I
literally see it happening because you
know the only way to really make it
happen is if like Sony gave up all the
stuff to venom in spider-man and
everything which they're not gonna do
and it all went over to Marvel and
Disney ah which is not gonna happen
and then in turn like they totally
rebooted the character right that's what
we're talking about doing with the x-men
and the Fantastic Four they're gonna
reboot and retool them all the whole
thing is going to be completely reworked
and redone and and nothing it's gonna be
so starkly different from what we've
seen coming out of Fox there's gonna be
no confusion in terms of the fact of you
know is this the same as like the Fox
movies that we saw there'll be no
confusion there it'll be like a total a
total revamp and so so with that in mind
with venom you know because of the fact
that Sony just started it doesn't make
any sense that they would in turn give
it all up right I mean especially with
venom being kind of the foundation and
the basis behind their entire like
villain verse so I don't know I mean
it's a cool idea is a cool theory I've
seen floating around the internet but in
reality I don't really see it happening
there's there's no real way that it
because it's just it just doesn't work
you know it just doesn't really seem to
come together but I'm alone I mean you
guys post your thoughts you know you
guys are very very vocal you guys you
guys love telling me when I'm wrong
which is fine I never said that I was
always right anyway but but yeah I mean
you know it's it's it's it's a cool idea
it's an interesting idea but let me know
you guys thing down in the comment
section if you are new here to come this
explain which you guys to the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later
[Music]